hey I'm Kevin and I'm Jess hey I'm Jason
and I'm Brent
hi I'm Kashia hi I'm Penelope and today
we're gonna be drawing avatar from
memory not the blue people I've never
seen avatar wait you haven't seen it
either
how are we supposed to do this that's so
I'm only halfway through the first
season and so I hope we get a character
that I actually know today you'll be
drawing Katara
okay okay good good good tarah
I know Katara okay today you'll be
drawing Zuko I did today you'll be
drawing Aang okay that's the one with
the arrow I'm sorry
avatar stance I'm truly sorry for what
I'm about to pick because okay I've seen
the memes so the memes are like I know
that there's like bending of different
elements right so you have like an
airbender a firebender or waterbender
earthbender
that's what I think I know he's got off
arrow I'm not sure few wears pants
so are you re watching this show Brent
yes I am right in the middle of you're
watching it I have a roommate who has
not seen it yet so it's very important
that I educate them it's like one of the
best shows I think I agree it's one of
the best shows what are your biggest
influences it is like a lot in anime and
then definitely like heavy into comics
they mostly started with my mom actually
she collected comic books when she was a
kid
no kidding yeah cool mom yeah yeah she's
pretty great you know I'll be tell me
about your process when you started
drawing like what are your initial step
see I'm usually if you just start out
super messy and everything's kind of
squiggles on the nevermind
draw the spine and some version of a
skull oh good then from there just kind
of figure out what my gesture was going
to you know like all these moves were
based off of like real martial arts so
it's like am I like dude drawing a fake
martial arts stance you know yeah I
don't I'm trying to figure out her hair
so she's got that she's got like these
hair dealies
I'm like right that even her brother
makes is like the hair dealies the like
the the loops the loop things yeah my
credit little hair loops like isn't that
even it's a part of his culture too how
do you know what the word is for it yep
usually at this point I'll flip my
canvas just so that I can see like what
kind of problems I'm having with my
figure oh that's so smart is it because
it gives you a different perspective on
your drawing yeah it does it helps me
with the volume so like when you're
drawing one way and you think you know
it everything looks cool and everything
looks right once you flip it and it
looks real rustic it's like oh so just
you are a storyboard artist for Marvel
and other properties is that correct so
how did you get to that point you know
was your family always supportive of
your career in the arts I kind of knew
what I wanted to do very early on in my
life
my granddad actually he was kind of the
one that kept trying to curb my
enthusiasm kind of a deal he was one of
those guys that really wanted me to get
into science like the joke was every
time I asked or said like oh I'm gonna
be a I'm gonna be a singer I'm gonna be
a dancer I'm gonna be an artist I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna do that and he'd
always tack on astronaut at the end so
you be a singing dancing
ding astronaut astronauts the important
part Jasmine really it was a case where
like I 100% had to stand my ground and I
was like Papa I am going to art school
I'm going to be an artist I'm gonna make
this my life and I and this is what its
gonna be and then I went calling up the
phone
whoa and it was maybe a week later I get
a phone call from my granddad and he's
like you know Jesse I've seen so much
animation and commercials lately and so
is that like 2d like that's what you do
and I'm like that's that's that's a
bunch of stuff and so now I get calls
from him all the time being like you
know I just ran into this lady from
DreamWorks and I wanted to show her your
stuff and lo like he is he is my best
promotion that's like a complete 180 ya
know cool I actually know what Zucco's
hair represents in the show you know
what his hair is for like why he has it
that way no so Zuko on his head is bald
because he is disgraced he has a
disgraced Prince so he had to leave the
Fire Nation to go hunt the avatar but
he's got a ponytail because that's like
a sign of Fire Nation royalty so that's
why that's the only hair he has left
it's a little like reminder of his past
so I am thinking and I don't remember
what the bottom of her like tunic looks
like it's almost like a Aggie like a
right
Japanese robe kind of thing right right
but like this does she have like a flap
down the middle do you know what I mean
is that yeah so it's kind of its kind of
like a it's like a panel down the front
breeze down the front in the back that's
named oh and the back okay oh cool so
alright for once I remembered something
correctly something that I'm doing right
now am i drawing is I'm adding multiply
layers
I find multiply layers to be really
helpful in adding levels and making
things darker without making them muddy
and usually I use whatever color that's
predominant in my painting and this is
blue and with multiply it makes it like
a natural shadow that makes sense to the
eye mm right I when I first saw it I was
just like okay this is really cool and
then like the the really serious themes
taking so like executed so well like it
was basically a show about ethnic
cleansing you know like that's insane I
a kids show I know I keep watching it I
keep watching it and I have these
moments every episode where I'm like I'm
watching it it's like this was on
Nickelodeon yeah I am moving on to color
how are you doing I am moving to color
as well what yeah yeah adding some
swirling patterns to really make sure
that it's obvious that like he's bending
air but like what if he's not an
airbender and like who were just what
like his so his clothes were like
different shades of brownish red right
yeah I kind of cheated because I am
doing Agni Kai Zuko
so he's topless I drew them topless as
well oh okay good Qatar's colors are
she's dark-skinned yes because it's more
that's the kind of clothing she's
wearing is like Eskimo or Inuit style
clothes because she's in the Arctic but
because she's in all that snow so this
is my science hobby Thank You granddad
my science hobby coming back in because
she's in all that snow technically she
actually gets just as tan as if you were
at the equator because of all that light
reflecting off on all that snow mm-hmm
yeah and I got drama sort of like
ambiguous looking like thing going
through the air I think I'm gonna make
it into a dragon just because I think
that's gonna look cooler oh you're so
smart and it's like the mythos kind of
just makes more sense to me that way
pens down
how do you think you did Brent dude this
looks like Zuko I mean - some like
clothing some accessories you know you
can't you can't get much as you've got
more Zuko than this I'm gonna go out on
the limb and say this is the best
drawing I've ever done on draw off what
okay well Jason come on I think it looks
cool this is definitely leaning towards
what a bored pose would look like for me
mine turned out be a little honest mine
turned out a little more boyish than I
wanted okay I think I did pretty well
I'm pretty happy with the final product
I wish I knew a little bit more about
this character but I'm gonna remedy
that's dude how about you how'd you do
I did as well as could be expected all
right let's done them to each other you
nailed those like Fire Nation boots
that's really good oh look at his pants
oh he doing shoes you got it yeah don't
wear any shoes you know because he does
that leg sweep remember there's like
that one shot where he like sweeps the
leg I should have got some print do you
think this is the best drawing I've done
draw uh I would have to say I would have
to say your minion is still it's still
my top spot Jason it was fun yeah this
one lands on the top three I'll give it
that
oh it is so good I would totally date
this guy
I love the flowy air thing I totally get
that he bends air hopefully he does
I was completely off oh my goodness
I got orange in there I didn't have any
orange I had all blue in my DNA I didn't
get sort of this Cape shawl thing and I
definitely didn't get the colors right I
didn't know if you have staff I you know
I didn't know that that that was this is
really cool i love i love how we both
got stank face like those I mean you
gotta do stank face yeah how to do stank
face with the guitarra
wait she is about the business and the
clothes is so dynamic and like the arcs
of everything is just the arc of the
hair and ah okay okay oh man I forgot
her mother's necklace
we both did oh that's so integral to
character no no no I think you did an
amazing job and I think your pose is so
dynamic and I just want to know what is
the secret well it's uh it's five years
of Marvel kids it's drawing superheroes
either jumping fighting or yelling for
five straight years that's how you get
it that's the secret to dynamic
characters jumping fighting and yelling
and yelling
[Music]
[Music]